we have a voicemail number.
The number is two one nine two, David p.
Here's a question about the 2020 Democratic
primary
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Hey, David, I want to get your take on a,
okay.
Hey, a Sanders Warren ticket for 2020 maybe
it's too early to the two.
Um, [inaudible] say anything like that, but
I think, uh, they have a good chance of [inaudible].
Um, picking on Trump, you know, they joined
forces and we kind of hit them with everything
we got.
Um, yeah, I just want to get your take on
that David and enjoying the show.
So listen, I do think it's a little early
to talk about that.
I personally, I would love to in November
of 2020, uh, go and vote for Warren Sanders
or Sanders Warren personally.
I think that that would be great.
Uh, I am sort of skeptical of this idea that
Democrats always employ where they pick a
vice presidential running mate on the basis
of we want someone from the south or the Midwest
to appeal to evangelicals or whatever.
I think that that strategy is out and I think
we just need the best people on progressive
policy.
So I don't know the answer.
Um, we've talked before about, uh, when is
the right time to start having that conversation.
I don't know that it's now, but do think it's
pretty soon.
And, uh, the, the idea being we need to start
thinking more in total about what this ticket
is going to look like and how it's going to
be able to fight and run against Trump pence.
Uh, but on a personal level, I would love
to vote for Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
on a ticket no matter who is at the top of
that ticket.
Make sure you are a member or patron so that
you can get access to the daily
bonus show.
Sign up@joinpacman.com or patrion.com/david
Pakman show.
I'll see you then.
Otherwise, see you tomorrow.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.